can we talk about your two or three most
successful movies and then in contrast
your two or three movies that weren't a
success
we're talking like Financial correct
okay yeah I would say
um my most financially successful movie
in my career um was probably edges of
Darkness
um which I did in 2008
um it made I want to say it was it 96 it
was 96 000 in the first quarter like
when it came out this was in two eight
so like in Anchor Bay was the U.S
distributor it got a huge DVD release it
was in like like it was one of those
titles at Blockbuster where you know
like most Indie titles there'll be like
like one two or three this had like like
rows oh you know they're like rows six
or seven you know it was all over
Hollywood Video and it I I don't think
I'll I probably won't ever have one that
does like that good again well hopefully
I will but that one did really well you
know and um and honestly it was just and
I wasn't involved in the distribution or
marketing of it because it was all
through Anchor Bay and you know
Shoreline was our sales agent
um but I think uh it that came down to
just it was the it was the right genre
at the right time it was like before
walking dead or right at the beginning
of Walking Dead I can't remember which
but it was like like zombie stuff and
and I did the uh the sub genre combining
thing so it was like zombies it was a
zombie apocalypse but it was a story
about like vampires trying to survive in
the zombie apocalypse you know like
zombies are eating all their food so I
think that that mishmash really helped
it you know and it was also it was a
very diverse cast you know at a time
when diverse casting wasn't happening
that much at that level you know and um
that that did that did well
um in the documentaries
um I did one
uh two years ago um called alien
contactee and you know to be frank you
know it's technically not one of my
better documentaries you know it's
mostly a single interview
um we had trouble with the sound it's
not the best shot I didn't have really
good b-roll for it but the the subject
the interviewee he was so engaging and
he had such a strong like following that
wants and needs his information that it
did really well like it was doing four
or five thousand a month you know for
almost a year and and this is something
that we made like literally for nothing
you know like shot the interview with
the guy I think I edited it in like
six or seven days like really quick and
you know and didn't have much hope for
it I was kind of like you know I'll see
what it does and it it took off
you know sorry who was the is he like an
expert yeah yeah his name's uh Louise Dr
Louise Turi um he's a he's a astrology
Guy and um he speaks he he was he was an
alien contact to you as someone that's
had you know experiences you know
meeting or you know seeing aliens you
know and he has a website where you know
people sign up and they get his
astrology stuff and he has a pretty big
following so one thing especially in the
screaming world if you have a subject or
you know an actor that's going to gain
or a influencer that's going to gain a
lot of early momentum for your movie
that momentum can carry it to a bigger
audience you know because they're
basically training the algorithm who to
show the movie to so if you have a movie
like alien contactee where this guy has
I think I think he had like maybe 10 000
regular subscribers on his website which
isn't a huge number but if you have you
know five or six thousand of them that
watch that movie in the first week and
they're all like perfectly targeted for
him so the algorithm is going to show it
the more people like them and that's how
things you know go viral and that it
basically went you know like the Amazon
equivalent of viral you know it did
really well did and that was one that
ended up getting purged on Amazon but
then it later it got picked back up
later and started making money again
just not quite as much and it stayed
steady and it keeps getting on new
platforms it's doing well on YouTube
um really really well and then
um
another one in the Paranormal was the I
want to believe it was a UFO documentary
we went to a UFO convention and just
like like bum rushed the speakers like
hey can we get yoga in the corner and
shoot an interview for 50 minutes we had
one guy that agreed to do like a
two-hour with us and that was uh Nick
Pope who he used to be the British uh
um shoot I forget this title uh
something in defense like like his he
was basically like the British Mulder
you know and uh from X-Files and he
would uh so he we interviewed him for
two hours so he was kind of the the you
know the main part of it and we
interviewed another six people for it
but did all the interviews over the
course of two days
um I think I spent I spent less than a
month editing it
yeah maybe three weeks and uh and it was
a lot of stock b-roll and you know then
b-roll from the convention but but it
turned out really well and that
Community like I think was really hungry
for a documentary that wasn't like all
you know woo-woo and uh exploitive it
was just very like like brass tacks this
is what ufology is this is why we
believe in it
you know that that continues it was
never one of those that just like took
off and did you know 5 000 in a month or
nothing I think the most it ever made in
the month was like maybe 1500 but it's
been out for two years and it's it's
stayed there like every month yeah and
it's getting on new platforms it just it
just kicked off on a new YouTube channel
and it's doing really well so like that
continues to do great you know and then
you know narrative wise
you know the the company I was working
for and again I like I don't have their
books I just have their word for it but
you know like the talking dog Movie that
that probably that probably outdid the
edges of Darkness maybe five or six
hundred thousand
and then the ones that didn't do so well
what do you think was the difference
so
like rise of the undead my first one and
trap that was my third movie both of
those like I I really made them in the
dark like not thinking about audience or
any of that I'm just this is the movie
I'm gonna make I don't know who's gonna
watch it or where I'm just gonna make it
and and try to find distribution
and and I did but neither of those
movies did very well
you know like uh you know rise the
undead you know in the first iteration
of that we never I didn't and I didn't
see anything off of it you know the it
was a we did the deal with York
entertainment who was pretty notoriously
not great back then that are not in
business anymore and uh then trap I'm
trying to remember who distributed trap
I don't even remember I don't remember
rooster but we I didn't make much money
from this that one actually was only
with a distributor for about a year and
then I talked them into releasing me
from the contract and did
self-distribution with it made a little
bit and that and trap was so low budget
that I think it actually did eventually
make its budget back it was like I think
we made it for five
but um not well not that well but the
bigger one that really and the one that
pretty much made me almost quit
filmmaking was uh the campus or uh it's
called death day now ITN changed the
title so that just that one kills me
um so we we shot it in 2018 and you know
I I'd done all the other movies and I
was basically trying to follow the
business plan that like AMG the company
I worked for had laid out you know do a
movie for around 50 000 you have these
elements you know keep it low and you
know it was a single location horror
movie it had a mix of zombies ghosts and
uh
uh uh what do you call it a uh
um
like stalker slasher movie you know it
was it was a woman that was dying over
and over and every time she died she
would come back in a different like
horror movie scenario you know a little
death day but which is why they happy
death day which is why the distributor
actually changed the title to death day
to write off those coattails but anyway
we we finished it off and what had
happened was this was right so we
greenlit the movie like right as I was
like Amazon was about at its peak you
know and has this movie was greenlits
when Amazon did their first like take it
from whatever 15 cents an hour to five
cents an hour like took it down and the
market DVD like it was already shrinking
but it shrank really crazy between like
2017 and 2018 like the market just
wasn't there anymore not not like it was
so the movie came out and I was I was
projecting it at like you know like a
minimum it was going to make like you
know 3 000 a month but I was expecting
more like you know 20 000 a month came
out it made like twelve hundred dollars
a month one it made uh like a thousand
dollars a month to 700 month three it
was down to four on month four and then
I was like ah and the other big problem
was I initially I did not go with
distribution I was like I'm gonna
self-distribute this I'm gonna do the
Amazon thing and then I'll let filmhub
do the other things so I and I just done
the Amazon and it just wasn't going I
was like God we're never gonna make even
close to the budget back and I had all
of these investors and you know people
like talking about hey we need our money
back so I got a little bit like
desperate and like I need to find a
distributor for it and at that point
we'd already released it so a lot of
Distributors won't touch it so I found a
sales agent that could make a deal with
ITN and ITN would take it so I did and
the sales agent deal I just I didn't do
my due diligence it wasn't a great deal
and we like I think the movie made
around 30 Grand in the first year and we
never saw any of it so I ended up uh
threatening legal action against the
sales agent I got out of that deal and
now my deals directly with ITN so I get
the money directly from them but that 30
was already gone and it had already done
its two years so it's like now it makes
you know about a
thousand dollars or less a quarter
you know and and that money you'll just
I that I'll never be able to pay those
people back unless I do it out of pocket
which I've kind of started to do
but yeah and it was just you know I
didn't I I my eye wasn't on the ball you
know I was I was distracted by some
other things and other business stuff
and it just it didn't work out
do you think you'll ever use a sales
agent again I would never use a sales
agent again never you know and and I'm
not saying that they're not good ones or
whatnot but I just think that the market
has changed the only reason I even went
to that one in the first place was
because I made a huge mistake off the
bat like if you're
if you're going to distribute a thumb if
you're going to self-distribute and use
that's what you're going to do stick
with it go all in self-distribute if
you're going to do a distributor stick
with them you know like stop you know
don't try to don't try to pull it Midway
you know unless something's drastically
wrong like like honestly if I just would
have stayed the course with
self-distribution because I'm sorry I
said I was going to do film Hub but that
that's actually not 100 true because
film Hub I wasn't really aware of it at
that time like I I was just becoming
aware of it so like if if I just would
have held on to that for a year and then
done film Hub and the other platforms
and then it would have hit 2B and I
don't know that I would have saw the
whole budget back but I would have saw a
lot more than I did but you know I made
the mistake of you know getting
desperate and going for the sales agent
and the distributor and I'm not 100 on
the distributor either but I just you
know I I did it out of the desperation
and it was a bad move
with the alien documentary where you
went to the convention you said it was
pulled off Amazon but then put back on
was that because watch time was low or
you know it's really hard to say um so
you know Amazon has a thing they call a
customer engagement ranking and you know
it's what they base how much they pay
you now and if your ranking is so under
a certain amount there is a good chance
you'll get purged but the other thing
that could happen with the purging is
you know because people gotta remember
there aren't human beings like like
watching all these movies you know there
are algorithms there are third parties
that come in and they they they're just
scanning stuff you know like they're
looking for certain you know key phrases
or images that will spark something and
that's how red flags get sent up so on
the initial pass something might get
through that they don't like you know
but maybe it'll get discovered you know
or what they say is they're always
looking at you know audience data so if
you have a movie up and you know 100
people click on it to watch it and they
click off within 15 or 20 seconds
chances are that's gonna get that's
gonna get yanked you know so I I found
on the few that I had purged that it was
it had a lot it had more to do with
audience retention is what I would say
but I've heard other anecdotes about you
know stuff got pulled because it was too
you know the nudity was too extreme or
the violence or you know it was
political I've heard stuff like that too
but for me it was always watch time and
and to figure out your retention on
Amazon it's it's actually kind of easy
because they and their metrics they have
like your total amount of hours watched
and then they'll have your total viewers
and if you just take the you know total
time divided by the total viewers I'll
give you an average of how long they're
watching it you won't get the specific
metrics but you can get a ballpark and
if you have a if you have a 90 minute
movie and you know your your average
watch time is around 10 minutes that's
probably not great